one two three is how many times Carson
has beat cancer yeah sorry so cute thank
God for Marlo Thomas playing my mother
on friends look at that face just like
when you were a nice I'm and introducing
me to this incredible organization you
have a ton of celebrities on board can
you tell me how do they get involved do
you call them up personally yes how do
you do you do yes st. Jude's Children's
Research Hospital
why give to st. Jude our breakthrough
research is changing how the world
treats and defeats childhood cancer I
know what research means yes you do and
so should every parent ooh we're gonna
have fun come on in here my cancer was
in my blood and if they didn't get rid
of it I might have died we've been
fighting cancer for the last three years
so this is huge even just to get out of
the house much less fly to LA and meet
Jennifer Anniston this is one of my
favorite days of the year because I get
to meet these incredible beautiful brave
children Jennifer is a very nice person
she really cared for all of the kids
that she met coming from st. Jude a
little dinner for Jen's been giving back
for 13 years and still keeps in touch
with some of the families she's met her
favorite is the yearly birthday card she
gets from st. Jude signed by all the
kids we were gonna look for your name on
the star and we're gonna look for Johnny
Depp yeah yeah but me first yeah but Jen
isn't the only celebrity doing good
works here Sofia Vergara and Michael
Strahan are also lending a hand
appearing in the new campaign to help
raise funds for the hospital I come in
and I get a chance to hang out with
these kids who are be strong with people
I've never met
but they have so much joy and just to be
around them brings all of that to me
when he's cancer relapse Julian's mom
was devastated it was great to be able
to help them a little bit with the
English Sofia vegara at her wedding she
said don't send us a present send money
to st. Jude I mean god bless her on her
wedding day she shared it with the
families of st. Jude but a heart she had
michael strahan wonderful figure for
young boys and for fathers and uncles
and it's just it's just a great group of
people and I'm so so very proud like
that st. Jude is an incredible place of
hope and no family has to pay for
treatment it's basically a place to help
these children and these equally brave
family members who are going through
something that note no child or family
should ever have to go through
you